à à
ừ ừ
anh
alo alo chào các bạn
ờ ờ
xin lỗi vì hôm nay á muộn hơn vài phút
bởi vì à Vừa rồi mình có một cuộc gọi à
đồ xuất từ một người mà mình cũng không
ngờ đến đó là người thầy của mình à À
bây giờ là nào cũng tranh thủ là đang có
ít người nên mình chính chủ tâm sự một
tí nữa không ạ
thì người thầy của mình là người thầy
dậy
thi đại học của mình thì
thấy thế thế hạnh này Ờ
Thời đấy à kiểu nói như nào nhỉ Đầu tiên
thì tôi cứ phải nói hồi trước ở Tôi từng
nói là tôi gần như ạ kiểu chưa Thế
trường đại học mà tôi muốn thì ạ
[âm nhạc]
thì à Tôi chưa các trường đại học Tôi
muốn
sau đó thì tôi được gửi cái hấp Oh ở cái
trường BK két này thì bởi vì hồi đấy là
trường về cái này đi tuyển sinh ở khắp
các trường cấp 3 vào cho làm bài trắc
nghiệm bài trắc nghiệm tương đối dễ ảnh
khác để đạt được học bổng thì lại thành
thì lúc đấy thấy có mát Bách Khoa nên là
cũng hiểu thử đến xong rồi tìm hiểu các
thứ sau đó thấy có liên kết Garena hiểu
mấy ông thì được đó à Tớ nghĩ là về sau
tôi sẽ làm hacker hoặc à Làm lập trình
trên ngân hàng ra đăng ký và chiều nay
thì trường này thật ra vốn dĩ là nó rất
là nổi tiếng nhưng mà thời gian nổi
tiếng trước là nổi tiếng với bảo mật
mạng thì bây giờ thì ra vẫn nổi tiếng
bạn mật mạng nhưng mà cứ tưởng thời thôi
mà thấy hạnh về trường cũng về trường và
đúng về năm mà tôi về thì thấy
thì tạo hẳn một cái chương trình đào tạo
mới và lập trình ở bên trường này và
thầy khiến cho cái chương trình này giữ
ở thành công khiến cho là trường ngày
bắt đầu nổi hơn về bên công nghệ thông
tin lập trình chứ không phải về bên quản
trị mạng nữa
thì chị thì thấy rất là giỏi thấy kiểu
có tài không những là tài ăn nói trình
các thứ lại dậy thấy kỹ dậy được tất cả
các nguồn bé ông ạ Nếu mơ thấy dân thấy
tờ thanh toán và ra nhá thấy dậy được cả
môn Kinh tế dậy các môn em chẳng nói ra
thầy chém gió anh
đưa nhớ Bác với chị không cho anh nhiều
hơn thích
bởi vì em đối chiếu thả viên thể nhảy
luôn nỗ lực khác thì dậy thấy dậy được
cả
môn tin học văn phòng hay các thứ thứ và
đương nhiên ở cả lập trình
Ừ thì à
với nghe thấy không dậy ở bên A bên quản
trị mạng rồi bởi vì quản trị mạng thì à
luôn đủ giáo viên Chỉ có bên mình
mụn mấy cái lớp khác ngành khác thì
thiếu nên thành ra là thầy dạy mày cả
lớp khác và thấy rất là giỏi tôi vẫn
khẳng định là thầy có cái Tâm có cái tầm
các thứ
là đương nhiên là ở
kiểu về sau Đông sinh viên Đông giáo
viên hơn các thứ thì thấy càng có thêm
quyền và được kính trọng nhưng mà chính
vì như thế thành ra là tự nhiên ban giám
đốc ở trường tôi có gì đâu sợ Thấy sợ
Thấy quyền lực quá hay là thấy Thành nha
kéo cắt bớt trước của thầy đi Ê hồi đấy
là thầy á Thầy quản lý con người nhé
Thấy nói ai cũng nghe ai cũng để
thì thầy kiên Nói chung là trưởng phòng
đào tạo xong rồi về sau giờ tự nhiên là
bạn nào đốc hãy thấy quyền lực quá nên
các bước trước thầy đi để cho chuyển
hàng giáo viên bình thường
thì thầy phải thấy thế không phục nên
thầy nghỉ và đưa nhà sai nhỉ kéo theo
rất nhiều thầy cô nghỉ theo tự nhiên
trong đó về sau có cả mình mình thì thực
ra mình định lúc đầu là mình chỉ định ở
lại thường 25 để mà dậy kết thúc xong
một cái khóa thôi nhau do thiếu giáo
viên những Cả Thầy Cũng bà ở lại về mà
kèm có rò viên khác vì có vài giờ biến
mới vào nên là mình ở lại em khi thời đi
gái thì mình cũng kết thúc kể nốt năm
học đấy rồi mình cũng đi
Con Gà bây giờ là trường khá thiếu giáo
viên thế là cũng khó mà mình mà lại cũng
khó một cứu hết tất cả bạn đấy bởi vì vì
Ê mấy ông cứ hiểu giống như con rắn mất
đầu đấy
thấy đi rồi xong rồi để lại người người
phụ trách lại một người không hiểu mình
đang làm cái gì nó nó đi bị lại cường
xác
mà vừa rồi thì ở
mình nhận được cuộc gọi của thầy Thầy
bây giờ thấy vậy thấy rất có tài nên
thấy được trường khác chuyển về trường
đấy cho nó Tech và thầy đang gạ mình đi
dạy buổi tối
qua qua chỗ thầy dạy mình hồi trước đây
nhờ trường cũ cũng cạn mình dậy khát ham
cái tự thứ mình không thích rồi Mình đã
xác định ở cậu đi làm không quay đi dạy
nữa nhưng mà bây giờ bạn đang ngồi đây
thì tôi đang nghĩa là
là cũng có thể tháng 6 tháng 7 tháng 8
gì gì đó là tôi sẽ dậy hết Xong khóa đồ
ăn web nâng cao ý nghĩa không còn dạy
Online buổi tối mấy nữa thì chắc là chắc
là tôi sẽ
Ừ nếu mà tôi vẫn có hướng dậy buổi tối
kiểu nhà hết chả tôi sẽ qua lấy sẽ
parttime Tôi không nói về kiểm chắc thì
vào nhau chẳng qua tôi khá thích việc
đừng trên đốt dậy dậy online cái máy có
chị không vui bằng bình trên lớp rồi ông
ạ được người ta được mặt tôi tôi có biết
về ông ạ Tôi rất thích mặc Âu phục thì
thích mặc kiểu sơ mi của nâu cái thời sự
đừng bị Trên đây ngồi sau khi có thể
ngồi chém gió kiểu nhà nhưng mà người
khác vẫn là lắng nghe ạ
Hãy thì
Vì sao tôi thích cảm giác được điều lắm
hệ nhé Ai mà nó chắc rồi đấy
anh có thể tháng 7 tháng 8 có thể sẽ qua
đấy Dậy có thể rồi không biết được bởi
vì a tôi thì tôi ký hợp đồng 5 năm rồi
công ty này rồi thế tôi sẽ không thể bỏ
hạn đi làm công ty để đi dạy nữa quay
lại và tệ không muốn điều đấy nhưng mà
để dạy Park Ham và cũng như là nó không
khác gì bây giờ mà nó không
thì chắc là được là được
anh nói thế không phải là tôi dạy mày
ông à tháng 7 tháng 8 này đăng ký ở
không mấy cái trung tâm tôi dậy thì em à
đến đâu nhé Tôi cũng dậy chỉ dạy lại
toàn bộ những cái tôi ăn dạy Online ngay
thôi
ok ờ
ạ Bây giờ mà có hai mấy bạn nhỉ các nhòm
mà có nhóm nào hôm nay xung phong bảo vệ
nốt nghỉ còn một vài nhóm nữa thôi đúng
không
em ở công ty mình thì mình làm công nghệ
công nghệ gì ạ Cho mình áp dụng vẫn là
leo và vị vụ
vi của sai lầm nó là view views Yes I
à à
Ừ cái nhằm có nhóm Hôm nay bảo vệ nốt
nào nhận mình nhóm có lại rồi
à à
anh ạ
a cho tôi phải đánh dấu quân sư nhóm là
nó về rồi
ừ ừ
à à
ờ ờ
khi hợp đồng dài Bởi vì đó công ty pháp
và muốn kiểu làm caro dài gần bò đấy và
hợp đồng này hợp đồng để mà có cổ phần
thôi Còn thực ra là thực ra là mình
thích nhỉ lúc nào nghỉ được mà Chẳng qua
là có liên quan đến cổ phần I
Dạ Cháu chào chú
ơi hai mấy tuổi rồi tầm bây giờ 25 à 25
Nếu gọi tôi là chú cũng được
thì tự nhiên cảm thấy mình già đấy rõ
ràng là kiểu tôi Tôi bảo ở Nhiều lúc tôi
kiểu đi tôi đi ăn đi uống kiểu dạng là
bây giờ phục vụ đưa đôi khi sẽ trẻ hơn
tôi phục vụ gần nó nhất 52 Thôi thì
nhưng mà tôi vẫn gọi là anh chị có thứ
thứ vẫn Em cảm ơn ạ Rồi em xin cái cửa
thứ
anh không nhận ra mình đã già thế đâu
Ông gọi tôi là chú thì ông chịu à
à Có sao tôi không tự ái với gà cũng vui
mà khi mà mày ông gặp tôi ngoài đời bây
giờ thì có thể tôi đang Dầu Giây nhưng
mà
thôi cạo râu xong có mấy ông gọi tôi mày
tạo nên
đây những nhóm nó bảo vệ rồi đây còn
những nhóm chưa bảo vệ đâu nhỉ một tí
Lúc đầu Hết rồi à
hôm
nay còn những nhóm cho vệ là nhóm 2 này
nóng bởi ờ ờ
có mấy nhóm mày đâu hết rồi Củi khô mất
tích rồi vậy
nhưng có vài người dấu tôi rồi
ừ ừ
ở
đâu ơi Mình ăn ổi
và lẫn cả là
cũng có thể là hôm nay bảo vệ luôn cả
đợt 2 luôn đi hôm nay sẽ bảo vệ đợt 2
cho nhóm nào cần luôn bởi vì à à
à à khi
tôi thấy có phải tăng toàn rồi Cái cái
nhóm đợt 2 mà nhóm thứ hai có phải đang
làm sao ấy với thằng kiểm tra được tiến
độ mấy nhóm đây cũng chẳng báo cáo tiến
độ gì đó cảm thấy sai sai cái gì
ừ ừ
số
kinh nghiệm khi đi được tạp a gì
thì lời khuyên là các bạn phải xác định
tư tưởng là mình đi Mình đi thực tập là
mình sẽ học hỏi thí nghiệm mình sẽ bỏ
qua được tiền lương xuống hỗ trợ cấp cao
thường có thể ít nhưng mà quan trọng
mình phải học được việc đúng không Thế
nên là có những nơi mà có thể nó có thể
hậu hĩnh chợ có thọ Vĩnh hơn nhưng mà
các bạn sẽ học được cái gì cả thì các
bạn cũng Hóa Học được ít theo kiểu học
được tầm 12 tháng hết rồi Hoặc là người
ta đào tạo rất là chán đấy các bạn nên
nên nghĩ việc chuyển các bạn nên thực sự
là kiểu vào những công ty mà các bạn có
thể họ được rất là nhiều nên là thế
mà còn trọ học họ những cái mà về sau
dậy sang công ty khác cũng được Thế nên
tôi không lời khuyên mày không không nên
vào mình công ty làm được web hay là
WordPress mì cay có liên quan đến A
platform kiểu như thế hoặc là
làm marto tôi không thích mình cái đấy
vì mình cái đấy mấy ông chéo dụng ở
trong máy từ khi mặt phẳng công ty khác
thì kiến thức đấy nó chảy nghĩa gì cả
em gái
Ê mấy ông có thể mấy ông có thể thao
tiểu bảo ghét pp họp ra hai ngôn ngữ
khác cho tôi không quan tâm tôi sẽ không
thích Nếu nghĩ sang bên web với mà Zen
tô làm gì cả tôi thể tôi cứ mỗi lần tôi
gặp này cái sinh viên học cả đấy Kể cả
bạn thôi học người nghĩ rằng về sau nó
Nó kiểu nó cứ kiến thức nó cứ bị nóng
lông của dì và bảo hạ lạ học làm cái
khác với không làm được thế là tôi khá
phải chịu áo cảm khá nhiều
khi nghe tôi cứ quý ức trước và không
đôi khi là chúng ta phải độc tàn đi là
giống như thấy hạnh và tôi phạt đấy Đó
là
phải biết lắng nghe ý kiến người khác
đấy biết Cái bảo thủ của mình đúng đôi
khi chúng ta phải đọc tài chúng ta mới
làm được khá nhiều việc mà chúng ta là
Dân Chủ chưa nghe lời diễn ngày ý kiến
tới mọi người rồi cũ hài lòng nhìn Tiến
cho mọi người sẽ làm được cái gì ạ
di động
ở đâu mày nhóm khác đồ Alo tôi có quay
ngẫu nhiên nhé Nó quay ngẫu nhiên cho em
nhóm A có đây không nhớ à
em còn nếu mà hôm nay mà thật sự là
không có nhóm mà bảo vệ hoặc không xin
bảo vệ thì chắc là bắt đầu giống như bạn
kia bảo bắt đầu từ tuần sau đi Hà đâu
bắt đầu từ buổi sau chứ buổi sau tôi sẽ
bắt đầu dậy xanh nào pin nâng cao
Ừ anh MP3 Ok
số 53 đi tao lại nhà 13 trước đây ở
ở
nhóm 318 này
ừ ừ
à à
Ừ
nó 38
U22 Có Xương
ừ ừ
từ hôm nay cho tôi vẫn để auto đi cha
ông thể cháu hôm trước không vào đâu
à à
ừ ừ
anh alo bạn nghe Huế mình không ạ
bộ phim của
à à
ở Đông Đô hết ở cứ im lặng sợ vai
đang học với P thuần chuyển sang level
có khó không
nữa nó có khó điểm là nếu mà các bạn để
bạn chỉ biết mỗi TP không theo hướng đối
tượng hay không theo một Facebook không
theo mô hình bảo cái xe thì đúng à Bạn
phải học qua cái đấy trước đã rồi mới
hiểu được với leo nó là
các bạn hình dung Galile nó giống như
làm cái biệt thự cậu các bạn xây một
ngôi nhà bình thường sẽ 12 Tầng các bạn
quen được đấy rồi nhưng còn lao leo nó
giống như kẹo cả một cái lâu đai Còn bí
thư có hàng nó là như một mê cung ấy thì
có nhiều đương nhà nó sẽ đầy đủ tiện
nghi theo kiểu là các bạn muốn làm cái
gì cũng có nếu mà này nhà nó quá rộng
nên thành để các bạn khám phá hết cái
đấy ra khó thế a nếu mà các bạn đang từ
một thằng một kiểu mấy chỉ đang xây ngôi
nhà 12 Tầng nhảy phát ra cái biệt thự
như thế thì Chị Huệ bị loạn như là bạn
cũng phải thiệu qua mô hình mới xe OB
trước đã đầu mới mới họp leo mình cũng
sắp dạy cái mời Oppa luôn này
ở đó người nhiều nhóm mà đây là hôm
Nhưng mà mấy hôm trước cũng bảo vệ tương
đối rồi đúng không mình chấm cũng cũng
tương tương đối rồi mấy cái cần kiểm tra
lại là mày cái các bạn cần cập nhật lên
get mình chấm nốt Mày cứ điểm được tài
liệu Hãy điền về cốt
chờ tôi sẽ dành thời gian để chấm cho
chủ nhật tuần này tôi chấm hết lại một
lượt đi
đâu nhóm 13 đâu nhỉ
Ừ
bắt đầu Lâm
It is một mình à
Thế không được hả
anh em bảo và bật lên bảo em đi bảo vệ
của mình thôi
không nhưng mà buổi Sao bảo vệ được
không Chứ buổi bảo vệ nên nếu mà cả hai
cùng làm thì cả hai cùng lên bảo vệ con
bạn đấy theo các bạn nghỉ hẳn rồi thì em
mới vừa mình thôi
anh em không biết em nhắn lại bảo bạn
đấy là mấy buổi sau bảo viện không bạn
chưa dép em cũng
Ô thế cứ tặng tính sao đã đúng không ạ
cho con con nhóm nào nữa không nhỉ
vì sóng quá này có bằng không ạ Ừ
cho tôi không đại diện cho một ngày nữa
tục đơn vị tổ chức nào để mà cho cấp cho
các bạn cái bằng cả nhưng mà các bạn có
kiến thức cái điều đấy quan trọng hơn
bằng nữa nhiều
ừ ừ
a web học jaspas tốt chả chị w3school
với code academy cũng biết qua ra kích
cơ bản rồi
ừ ừ
ở đâu có nhóm nào nhỉ nhóm 3 hôm nay có
nhỉ
từ khóa sau á hóa sao chính là mình đang
định là nếu mà hôm nay mà
các nhóm kia mà không bảo vệ những kiểu
à mà ngọn vào buổi sau không có nhóm nào
đăng ký bảo vệ thì chắc à mình sẽ bắt
đầu dậy luôn từ thứ 7 thứ 7 này luôn Thứ
Ba đáng lẽ phải bắt đầu từ hôm mùng 1
vừa rồi đấy hơi bị mình hơi bị kiểu
tránh chương trình ấy
ở
nhóm 3 không có đầy đúng không
Tôi xem lại danh sách nhóm vật
a530 có này nhỏ ma
bài hát dạy lại từ đầu á Ờ không
khóa nâng cao chứ
các bạn ở có một bạn ở đây nha Mà Lâm
Tài rồi
a58 này nhóm 18 có được không năm 18
sau đám cưới hai ông kia ngủ ai kia đang
trong áo rồi Ờ nhóm 22 này
U22 có một bạn là ngon thôi nhóm hay cả
hai bạn đều đang họp
cho Java Có học chung luôn được copy và
MBC không
có mấy cái like Cũ Còn chứ mình có không
mình không dám à Ờ
Thực ra thực tế thì cái câu hỏi này là
cái câu hỏi mà ta thường có bạn hỏi mình
ở đây
Ô thế mình xin phép mình trả lời Hôm nay
mình xin phép trả lời hết mình cái câu
này tranh thủ mấy ông kia cho ngon nhá
Thứ nhất là về liên quan học Java này là
thực tế là các bạn nếu mà học được Java
học Song Song của pp này thì càng tốt
các bạn nên học Java ngay lúc này trước
khi mà người sang PC thì tốt hơn bởi vì
ah
ra Pa nó sẽ cho các bạn rất rõ và rất
sâu về aupair về hơn đối tượng nó sau
hơn cả TP nếu mà các bạn học được ra thì
hợp TP về hướng đối tượng lại dở ngàn ấy
a tiếp theo là đón hay nằm trong bao lâu
thì mình định dậy làm mới xe ốp Ê sau đó
thì mình chạy leo xong rồi Lúc mà bắt
đầu dạy razzil thì mình sẽ bắt đầu hướng
các bạn dần dần về làm đồ án làm tài
liệu này sau phân tích các thứ trước này
thì cái đồ ăn nói chung là mình hạn của
mình sẽ định Tháng 7 hoặc muộn nhất ở
cho tháng 8 thôi Và đã đã đến lúc bảo vệ
đoàn 2 tiếp theo là
có bạn bảo là tại sao mình mình không
nhớ của video nào mình từng nói với cái
vụ là à
em về phiên bản ngôn ngữ
mình không nên nhắc Nếu mà khi mà mình
thuyết trình cái tài liệu của mình khi
mình Đề cập về việc là sử dụng ngôn ngữ
Công nghệ ngon phiên bản bao nhiêu cái
xử thứ là để bởi vì a
Ê mấy ông ấy ông nhớ họa trong slide
thỉnh thoảng tôi đã cả tài liệu thôi bà
có ghi phiên bản vào ấy để làm gì để mà
để mà cái đấy liên quan việc là mình cấu
hình cho một con server một con hosting
của mình về sau để mà cắm trại qua web
mình thì mình phải cấu hình như thế nào
để phù hợp với các phiên bản ngôn ngữ cơ
sở thứ là sử bây giờ là pp bây giờ lên
đấy hẳn V8 rồi nhưng nhiều con Út sinh
đưa nó trị hỗ trợ p72 ap-596 lòng ạ thì
nó không chạy được trên của không chạy
được trang web của ông này ạ Đấy Thế mấy
ông phải khai rõ phiên bản ngôn ngữ cũng
như hệ được mấy cái kiểu hệ cơ sở dữ
liệu bằng vân vân
tiếp theo giáo án đồ án 2 thì là nó sẽ
vẫn khá giống đòn một nhưng mà nó riêng
để phân tích Chức năng này nó sẽ dài hơn
rất nhiều Bởi vì tôi sẽ yêu cầu không
thích rất nhiều Chị đồ ăn hay nó sẽ rất
nhiều tính năng khó và rất nhiều tính
năng phức tạp nữa thì miếu phải phân
tích mình cái điều đấy bữa ăn Anh khá
đơn giản phân tích nó chẳng có gì cả
nhưng một đoạn thứ hai ở sẽ rất phức tạp
nhưng tôi yêu cầu đồ ăn hay thì cái đoạn
phân tích Chức năng ở sẽ ra ăn rất nhiều
lý nhất là phải in ra thì cứ cho là tầm
20 tính năng Gì đó Gì đó đoán một thì
làm gì có tính năng gì để mà phân tích
mấy đâu
tiếp theo là
bởi vì đón một này cá nhân mình thấy ở
ra là cũng hơi sai sai khi mà kiểu
cho các bạn đăng ký ở nhà rồi các bạn ấy
nhỉ Tôi không biết làm thế nào để ngăn
vụ này có ông cứ bảo nộp tiền rồi cô ấy
thì chả hay là thậm chưa trả lại trả lại
cho người nào lại thôi kệ như thế nếu
tôi không thích gì đến tiền ở trong cái
này vẫn đã tự nguyện và tôi vẫn muốn cho
mấy ông Trải nghiệm thực tế là thực tế
đi làm với ông cũng sẽ gặp những cái
kiểu đồng nghiệp có thể người ta đang
rất gắn bó mình rồi họ vì lý do cá nhân
họ bỏ Ừ thế là đi làm thực tế rồi như
thế nào Tôi muốn điều hòa nóng như thế
bà cũng cũng là vì như thế này nặn thành
viên đồn hai tôi cũng sẽ sắp xếp lại kể
cả rủi đoàn một các bạn đang làm việc
với nhau rất ăn ý rồi tôi vẫn sẽ sắp xếp
lại vì đời thật ra không như mờ thế
không nói chuyện mà ông sẽ làm gắn bó
lâu dài với một đồng nghiệp Nếu là ông
vẫn sẽ phải ghét với người mới nó giận
chị ông ghét người mới mà người mới bỏ
thì ông không quay lại với người cũ đâu
hãy chấp nhận sự thật là như thế
dự đoán hại Nói chung là mày không phải
luôn tưởng là thứ nhất là không có sao
Khánh mình cả mình tự gánh phần của mình
Thứ Hai nếu mà giả sử mà ông kia của
mình đi mình cánh đuôi của phải lo mày
thận thiếu gì nhỉ Mình Anh hết đấy Minh
càng gánh thì mình càng có nhiều kinh
nghiệm làm đồ ăn này có kinh nghiệm mà
chứ có phải là để để chấm điểm hay là để
khoe cái gì đó đâu không cần phải so
sánh với nhóm khác nhóm khác thì hai ông
siêu sao làm ngon lành nhỏ mình thì hai
ông cùi bắp rồi Ông kia nhỉ đã chẳng ăn
không mình không rõ ràng như thế Mình họ
cho mình mà đúng không
nên nên là mấy ông phải phải xác định
được cái tư tưởng đấy Tôi đang cố muốn
năm ấy ông xác định tư tưởng Đấy là học
cho mấy ông rồi họ theo tôi không phải
gì cả đúng không Nếu làm được điều đấy
gì áo bóng đá chiến thắng bản hợp đồng
cho trước mắt là như thế
em cầm Chiến Thắng người khác thì thì
còn nhiều như tố nữa
Tí học đồ án hay mình sẽ làm về cái gì
thì như tôi thường ai nói nó là thứ nhất
là chắc là nó không về tin tức hay bán
hàng nữa đó là bài toán hình nghiệp vụ
đó là kiểu nó phải ra phương tại giống
như là quản lý cái gì đó quản lý trường
học quản lý thư viện Quản lý cái gì đó
Nói cho tôi sẽ
đề tài vẫn là đề tài khá là mở mấy ông
thích làm cái tool là một cái tiện ích
gì đó thì cũng được nhưng mà về sau tôi
sẽ duyệt cái này đấy Để xem nó ổn cho
phù hợp đồng nai không Và nếu mà nếu
không nghĩ được ho gà mấy ông nói chung
là bí dưỡng thì tôi cũng sẽ gửi cho tầm
15 20 cái đề tài mẫu ở trường cũ của tôi
đến mấy ông có thể tham khảo thì
em tham khảo nhá Mấy ông mà làm giống
giống hết mấy đề tài đấy bị trùng thì
mấy ông lại cảm thấy nản Thôi thì thì
mày ông cứ nghĩ trước về các đề tài mình
làm cứ ngỡ như là mình còn phải chưa
nhóm Nữa trọn đời trai chắc à Thứ bảy
này để cứ tuần sau dư ra đi tôi sẽ xem
thế nào rồi tôi sẽ lại cho con đăng ký
đồ ăn hai và lần này tôi sẽ
từ ông Thiện nói 80 20
thì
yên tâm đồ ăn 2 lần này tôi khẳng định
có khí đông hơn đồ ăn một bởi vì có khá
nhiều ông ở kênh của tôi tôi biết đó là
có biết level rồi có kinh nghiệm rồi và
học kể làm đồ ăn bột này khá trám được
thì mấy ông có thấy có phải ông làm đồ
ăn một thì ngon lành ngon nếu người áp
dụng công nghệ gì đó đây Bởi vì ông ấy
biết xử mấy cái này rồi ông vào làm cho
vui thôi mà có như ông còn chưa làm
không thời gian và làm cơ đón hay tôi sẽ
Ừ ông ấy vào miệng sẽ thấy Tuấn hay là
có thể sẽ đông hơn và sẽ có vai ông có
ông đi làm rồi ông mới vào làm đấy nên
là nó sẽ khác đây là quy trình làm đồ án
2 thì nó sẽ hơi bị khác của Đoàn một bởi
vì đón một thì à
cho tôi cho béo làm tài liệu sau cùng
làm đúng không ạ Nếu không sẽ phải làm
tài liệu trước tôi duyệt trước rồi mày
ông ấy bắt đầu được cốt đấy cái lớn nhất
thứ hai đó là đương nhiên là vẫn phải
duyệt cơ sở liệu duyệt Phân tích các thứ
gì trước nữa ngoại
rồi khá nhiều cái mới ông sẽ phải tự làm
thủ công tôi sẽ dậy mấy ông nhưng mà sẽ
không dậy theo kiểu là
cầm tay thì lỗi nhiều mặc và tôi không
up code lên thành đoán hay Cốt nó sẽ khá
lằng nhằng đấy Tôi không up code lên thì
thành ra mấy ông sẽ khó mà theo rõ được
mình không phải hiểu được là tôi đang
Em đang làm cái gì thì thôi chứ mấy ông
cũng bởi vì nó chuyện nhỏ rất nhiều file
Tôi muốn nhảy từ file này sang file kia
là nó không có thể bị loạn đấy tôi sẽ
cân nhắc thời vụ là tôi dùng cái tiện
ích ra like cốt để mày không thể xem
được cốt của tôi nhưng mà hình như cái
thế giới hạn chỉ trong vòng 50 người hi
vọng là lúc đấy Tôi hi vọng đấy nó không
đông lắm chứ nếu mà đông quá thì lại
cái like cốc không có vấn đề gì hơi buồn
thì
cái thì tôi sẽ cho tiện ích đấy thì mới
không thể vào từng file để xem được lúc
mà tôi đang cốt Nhưng mà khi mà tôi tắt
đi nhưng mà tôi không like nữa thì người
ông sẽ không có cốt mẫu đàn ông tham
khảo thì nó không phải xe mạnh video mà
không phải hiểu được tôi đã làm cái gì
mà Vân Đông ạ
Ừ ok nãy giờ nói có thể khá nhiều B số
lượng đến đúng phết rồi có nhóm nào xin
bảo vệ không nhỉ
khi
em mới vào
đăng văn ký đăng kí bây giờ là đăng ký
đồ ăn hay thì đăng ký ở thôi đồ ăn đấy
đồ án nâng cao còn đón một Thì bây giờ
mình không cho đăng ký đoàn một nữa gửi
quá cũng qua sánh mới rồi
cho tôi mấy ông kia đâu hết rồi Hôm nay
buồn tâm sự thật à
anh alo
à à
Xin Chào bạn công ty của mình có một số
hợp tác mong để trao đổi bạn Bạn liên hệ
mình sẽ tìm hiểu nhé Mình không phải là
người nói dối bạn yên tâm là mình chỉ
đang tìm lạp lạp lạp là
ơi mẹ chưa cộng hòa bình nhắn tin nữa
tôi quá
anh nhìn nếu như thế này thấy không uy
tín rồi
anh không
ừ ừ
cô bạn kia vừa nói là ờ
em có bạn nào vừa bảo là
Anh em nhóm 3
bạn kia xin nghỉ à
anh không ai tới trình nhìn tâm sữa
nhà ông còn tâm tôi tâm sự gì tiếp Nếu
không có lấy Hỏi đi
chứ không phải tôi sẽ ngồi chém gió thì
đôi khi hơi lan man tí
nhạc karaoke Mấy ngày hôm nay tôi cũng
hơi bị à
xã hội bị bận rộn tí
khi vận dụng ức Hạnh sở Kiều hộ Minh còn
à
khi tâm sự về thời gian mới ra trường
cái khá hay này
tôi từng nói là trường tôi trường nghề
nên là tôi học xong cái 52 thôi mà làm
xong da đang làm giữa đồ ăn hay Tôi đã
được đi thực tập rồi và và tôi
Ừ thôi bảo rồi mới hồi đấy à Tôi cần có
kinh nghiệm nên thành ra là
trà
xanh thành Gala châu Á
khi
người ta trả xã Đèo từ kiểu 500 Xong về
sau toàn Fullham lên một triệu Tôi vẫn
chấp nhận làm đến lượt à à là mấy nửa
năm rồi tôi mới nghỉ Thời đấy tôi học Ôi
đầy hồi mà trước
trước khi vào công ty đấy à Tôi còn chưa
biết lao leo cái gì chưa biết Yuri chưa
biết bút tre và cái gì vậy Ở trường thôi
chỉ được dậy mới shopee thuần thôi thì
xin vào công ty mà biết được toàn bộ mày
đấy hồi hội cái những ngày đầu tiên vào
tôi vào cùng một bạn nữa
đi
sói người ta gửi cho một đống link trang
chủ nào em tranh thủ Wechat người đọc đi
Em tự nhiên toàn bộ bằng tiếng Anh ngày
hôm sau được đưa đi cùng tôi nghỉ luôn
không không dám đi đã tôi cứ thể ngồi
đọc gặp tận hai tuần cũng hiểu tương
đồng nhưng mà cũng chưa bắt tay vào làm
được cái gì cả cho anh ấy bảo là em cứ
làm CRD thử bản cá thu thứ đi mấy hiểu
được ngồi đọc không hiểu được đâu
ờ ờ
như vậy sau đó thì đứng yên là làm xong
thì tôi bắt đầu hiểu được về mình cấu
trúc nó các thứ chứ mấy hiểu được nó vẫn
hàng như nào sau đó cứ làm dần dần tự
nhiên là về sau tôi vẫn làm được việc
em
vẫn làm được việc nhưng mà tôi bị vẫn
còn bị
hỏng cái nước nhiều mà vừa học trường
nghề rất là bị lý thuyết kiến thức lý
thuyết ra yếu thuật toán yếu xong rồi à
Ừ nếu mà các bạn chỉ cắm đầu vào làm thì
các bạn chỉ biết làm thôi các bạn sẽ
không biết cái tối ưu lắm đấy rồi về sau
tôi còn phải đọc thêm nhiều tài liệu và
cũng bị mắng suốt về cái vụ là kiểu
không tối ưu câu câu truy vấn SQL này
không không biết làm nơi ở cho nó phát
nhanh hơn này công ty startup công ty
nhỏ và tôi khuyên mấy ông cũng thường
tôi khuyên để ông nhờ vào cũng tính nhỏ
để mà người ta đào tạo người ta còn là
mình còn làm mình còn được động và nhiều
thứ công ty lớn thì nó sẽ có đào tạo
chuyên nghiệp cũng có con ơi là dõi
nghiệp Nhưng mà mình mình được bảo mà ít
lắm mà người ta không quan trọng mình
lắm Tôi cũng nói rồi nó mấy ông nhỉ
người đã không quan tâm không đến muộn
rồi là không có tâm ở đây là công ty nhỏ
thì ông sẽ được nhảy vào làm thẳng dự án
thực tế luôn ông sẽ cảm thấy mình quan
trọng và ông cho cô
Nói chung à à với cái chí mấy ông nữa mà
em ký của mấy ông là theo kiểu là ông
thích có người thuốc không Hay là ông tự
học được không hiểu
có rất nhiều yếu tố nữa mà à
ừ ừ
từ
tháng 5 này em có tín chỉ được tập nhưng
mà vẫn chưa tìm được công ty quan trọng
gì tín chỉ đâu em quan trọng thì mình
cái kiểu
bằng cấp có gì đâu
tất cả bạn cơ học xong mà chìa khóa sau
của tôi vẫn tự tin là mày không đi làm
các thử ngón like họ ra đấy Tôi đang một
loạt hồ sơ xin việc rồi đấy mấy ông ạ à
mày cái gì đi mình cái hồ sơ ơi để à Cái
gì gọi là yêu cầu yêu cầu công việc đấy
ở trên đường Linh em mấy ông nhỏ cái ông
mà chỉ đi Có đi
chặng tỷ lệ tí thôi mọi ăn cho mèo
à à
xe
tải máy ông mày không vào đường link này
để mà mày ông xe mà mày cái gì đi Tôi đã
tổng hợp đây xem file excel tiện từ tổng
hợp bằng phải sao đây có rất nhiều công
ty người ông thích công ty nào để đăng
ký vào ứng tiền tao mày công ty đều đang
tuyển à
We are English course
anh à Ừ tôi hình trước đi mô tả phần đến
có đúng không
À không có gì
khi sex
à à
hỗ trợ bảo sao tự nhiên là mình quên mất
tự nhiên thấy có cái một ngưỡng nào đó
tự nhiên là số lượng thành viên công
tăng lên nữa với mình không để lên đi có
phải đâu cả
những người gà Tôi không muốn đông quá
đâu bơ đi có của tôi giờ hơn 400 mà thực
ra là này hiện tại bây giờ đang có mỗi
năm mấy người đã ngon nhờ thực sự xem
mình tắt tôi tan tác everyone vào nên
thực sự ông nào thực sự muốn thì ông ấy
mình lên vào chứ không thì cái tát Thế
chỗ cảm thấy phiền lắm nó luôn hỏi lại
tôi rồi kìa bạn có muốn
gửi Star thận 400 người không đấy rõ
ràng là tôi không hề muốn điều đấy rồi
rõ ràng tôi biết thừa có nhiều ông vào
đấy chẳng để làm gì cũng chẳng bơ thảo
luận cho các thứ tư cũng không đăng ký
gì cả
Ừ tôi không thích tôi không thích mình
theo phong trào bao giờ nên Hãy nghe tôi
khó chịu phải điều lắm
có thể tội đi lọc một lượt
cho tôi đã nghĩ thế đấy thì ở có khi tôi
làm con tôi ngồi livestream cốt cốt cái
đoạn mà thằng this code này và các bạn
telegram rất ngon mà gái kia của nó thế
Mình muốn cốt một cái gì đó thì mình cứ
lên đọc tài liệu nó api rồi mình làm nên
là tôi hoàn toàn có thể là chỉ cần kiểm
tra mày ông đấy nằm không nằm trong danh
sách các nhóm của tôi và chưa từng nhắn
tin trò chuyện gì ở trong máy kinh chat
thì tôi hoàn toàn có thể
kiểu kích thích thôi ba này hơi quá chặn
hơi quá Tôi sẽ đá đít ra khỏi kênh this
code để trong đỡ nhiều chồng nhiều ai
hơn 400 vẫn cảm thấy nhiều khi mà
Ẩm Thực sự thì không biết bé ông ấy thế
nào
em hiện tại bây giờ này đang on 81 người
cùng xem Ở đây ít xem đây ít hơn sẽ rồi
tôi không quan tâm số lượng người xem
nhưng mà trông nó cứ kiểu bị sao ấy
Ừ
tối hôm nay mấy ông kia không định bảo
vệ thật mà
mẹ
con lên á con ăn thì ở
Tôi có đăng bài nhưng mà tôi hướng đến
tôi có khi ở trong bài đăng đó hướng đến
bác em nên là ra là người ta thường em
gửi tôi với bác em cũng như là tôi có
ghi ở mọi nơi rồi nhưng mà không hiểu
sao họ vẫn thưởng trả họ lại vào lọc của
tôi kiểu gì vậy mà gửi cho tôi nhiều về
bên Hà Nội nhiều hơn
an toàn Hà Nội này nó ít Hồ Chí Minh
nhưng mà ở
à à
bài hát mấy ông có vào lý Core item mày
không phải thuộc nhóm nào đó mà đăng ký
làm đồ ăn đúng không có bình luận nhắn
tin gì đó
ừ ừ
từ hôm nay thực sự sẽ Nhăn nhó thế vậy
sao
hả Bây giờ tôi chuyển có tâm sự gì nhỉ à
tự học tiếng Anh à
từ hôm trước tôi hôm trước tôi ở
anh nghe lại được một cái video người ta
nói cái vụ đầy Cả hai đó là ờ
những miếng học tiếng Việt như nào
Ừ nếu học tiếng mẹ đẻ của mấy ông như
Ừ nếu không có đọc sách sách tiếng Việt
để bé học Tiếng Việt không
Vui lòng xem nhiều phim học tiếng Việt
không ạ
Mỹ Tâm
Ừ nếu học tiếng Việt như nào
tự học Tiếng Việt học cái tiếng đang nói
như thế nào
Ừ anh chị đơn giản là kiểu mày không
tiếp xúc nó hàng ngày Nếu không phải
lắng nghe phải phải hiểu phải cố hiểu
thôi em có mấy ông còn bé tí
Ừ đúng ạ
Ê mấy ông có học đứng như mếu cũng học
viết mày không cũng học đọc em cũng học
nói
Ừ nhưng mà thực sự thì lúc nào để mà Mấy
ông hiểu tiếng Việt có thử mấy ông có
xem có phim không
à Dạ không Nó học tiếng Anh nếu mà để mà
thực sự học tiếng Anh ấy không phải phải
đắm mình ngoài xong nó giống như tiếng
Việt đấy nữa không phải ép mình nghe ép
Minh Hiểu nghe thường xuyên nghe mỗi
ngày như thế là phải cố hiểu OOO
anh nó cất giống như là một người rừng
một con người của mình bình thường như
bây giờ đi Sao tự nhiên mình bị lạc sang
đất nước khác tầm chỉ cần 12 tháng là
mình cũng bắt đầu hiểu người ta nói được
vài câu cơ bản mình cũng nói được vài cô
bạn Tại sao
Ừ thôi Của mình chưa từng biết ngôn ngữ
của họ là cái gì luôn Nhưng sau 12 tháng
mình cũng bắt đầu bởi bởi vì sao chúng
nhất là con người của mình có nhu cầu
giao tiếp thứ hai là mình có khả năng
học hỏi mình cũng hiểu mình mình cũng
cậu cú muốn hiểu
Ừ thì mình sẽ học được
à Còn bây giờ để nghe bất kỳ người nào
dạy mấy ông về học tiếng Anh được đọc
sách này rồi nghe phim này rồi nghe nhạc
này hay vân vân thì cứ nghĩ là đấy vậy
tùy từng người đấy thì đừng người có
người học Ví dụ nhé Có thể loại Riêng
việc xem phim anh nghe nhạc thế thôi
có người nghe nhạc mà chỉ quan tâm thì
nữa nhạc chứ không quan tâm đến lồi cũng
người xem phim thì cũng chỉ để ít tình
tiết phim chẳng câu chữ người ta nói là
cái gì nên thành ra là cũng chẳng học
được cái gì cả nên là chỉ có thể hơn đàn
ông đắm chìm vào thì ông sẽ sẽ tự nhiên
tự nhiên thành thói quen thôi nếu có vấn
để ý và mấy ông đã học được bao nhiêu
chữ tiếng Việt không nói được bao nhiêu
có tiếng Việt không không không mấy ông
học từ mới tiếng Việt kiểu gì không tiếp
xúc quá nhiều mình học được thế thôi
đúng ạ
Ừ đúng rồi bạn kia cũng nói đúng đấy mày
Cái người trên núi người ta có đi học
người yêu hay là vẫn có thể người ta
người ta gặp tiếp xúc nhiều xong người
ta cũng cố muốn học vài câu để mà cậu
nói chuyện với người Tây thấy người ta
muốn học đấy Xong rồi ta cổ và người ta
tiếp xúc nhiều đấy cái nói được em nó
sói nói đúng không
và sau quá này thì mình sẽ làm khóa nâng
cao nữa thôi Sau đó thì như vừa nãy mình
nói là có khi là mình sẽ qua một trường
ở trường của thầy Mình đang phụ trách để
mà mình dậy thấy bảo là hiện tại đang
thiếu giáo viên vãi Eo vọng Bởi vì thực
ra bây giờ cái ngành này nên cũng không
tin là tuyển người làm công nghệ tin là
khó với có tiền người dậy công nghệ
thông tin mới khó hơn
nếu không hiểu đều đeo và
ông bà sinh viên ở bên trường đấy có vẻ
đông phết thì nói hơn nghìn người ở cái
được
cho tôi tôi từng đứng ở trước hội trường
để nói chuyện trước 500 người rồi nhớ
tôi chưa từng dậy Chắc tầm 100 200 người
rồi à
Ừ thế biết cảm giác thế nào
Ừ nhưng mà chắc chắn là tôi nghĩ nó sẽ
phát khác một tí sau cái thời giờ dậy ở
trường cũ rồi trường cũ thôi hai lớp -
22 năm người già càng thôi là tôi sẽ đi
khi tôi cầm tay xin lỗi cho từng bạn một
thì tôi biết tính cách từng ông này sôi
biết từng ông năng lực trình độ như nào
vậy thôi luôn kiểm tra luôn đi cốt của
mấy ông này
còn nếu mà Đông Hưng Tôi chưa biết là sẽ
dạy cho cả như thế nào
em lại online nghe mấy ông Thực ra thiệt
đấy
Ừ nếu mà dậy được tôi mà rảnh thì không
có offline Chắc chắn là tôi nghĩ là tôi
sẽ có thể tôi sẽ khiến cho mấy ông nha
bị à
em bị bị động hơn rồi vừa tối sẽ chủ
động khá nhiều Tôi sẽ giúp đỡ mày không
khá nhiều
Ừ nhưng mà tôi khẳng định tôi sẽ hiểu
được mấy ông hơn để mà khắc phục được
mấy ông tránh việc bị bỏ như này Xa Lạ
cách tải Attack ít à
30 trở ra cũng được
em không ra thì đang bảo là 1.000 lắm
chui ở Tôi sẽ dậy hai ba lớp à
Anh lại đang thiếu giáo viên đấy phải
đâu thì chạy gồm đâu đấy à à
Anh ở nhắc lại thời đi dạy vẫn cảm thấy
hồi hộp cái gì vui phết
anh thấy vui mà tôi tôi đứng dậy đứng
dậy cho lớp không không nhỉ thời gian
luôn
mà ngày nào cũng dậy nhưng mà dậy nhiều
hôm dậy kiểu gần lần này 11 12 tiếng
nhưng tôi cũng cảm thấy cậu ấy ăn cho
con nhé
ờ ờ thầy của tôi đang làm phụ trách và
Đào tạo đã tạo bên đấy nên chắc Lách qua
được cái vụ bạn đại học nhưng mà thực ra
tôi cũng tôi bảo tôi đang học liên thông
ở chỗ sắp có bằng một
thích thì nếu mà không thì mình sẽ phải
học thêm cái kính chỉ cả tôi trả lại ở
yêu cầu dạy
đại học
em yêu cầu để giải đại học
giảng viên đại học bằng tiến sĩ về
chuyên ngành Đảng viên nào sáng à
à mà trường đã nói lại học
cô thạc sĩ
ở trường tiểu học vấn ở
có bằng tiến sĩ trước nhà ngủ dậy
xe không kính tiến sĩ này không
Ê hồi nãy tôi đọc mà chỉ cần bằng cùng
nhân với cái á tín chỉ chứng chỉ dạy
chứng chỉ sư phạm là được rồi nhưng có
vẻ Bây giờ nó khác à tổ không rõ nữa
Không nhớ mấy cái vụ này đâu thế ra tôi
tôi là một người rất thích đọc về luật
giữa thích đọc luật nhưng mà ạ đều nó
thay đổi khá nhiều không rõ được nữa
anh nói hình như là phải lên thạc sĩ
không á Cái đấy tôi tính sao
à à
em đã học nhiều quá rồi không tốt
ờ ờ họ khắp nhiều quá đấy tôi Tôi từng
nói rồi mấy thầy cô bây giờ dạy công
nghệ tin bị học nhiều quá lý thuyết
nhiều quái
Chú dạy kiểu nó cứ chán chán của gì
không thực tế ở vì người ta chỉ có mỗi
lý thuyết chỉ cắm đầu ở bên mỗi lý
thuyết Nhưng tôi không thích kiểu đấy ạ
Ừ đúng rồi Mình cũng ở lại trường được
mình là mình học xong mình cũng được ở
lại trường để dậy đấy mà mình nghĩ à Ờ
chú ý nghĩa là thực ra không cần phải
khắt khe thì cái vụ đấy chứ kia đại học
thôi còn may mà mình tạo một cái trường
nề về sau thì mình cũng mới định vào đại
học tử tế nhưng mà cái thứ sau A
Ăn sáng chưa mà mình đang định
về trường của thầy mình Aptech nó trừ
nghề chắc là không phải yêu cầu bằng cấp
gì cả
có bằng cấp quan trọng gì bây giờ Tôi
khỏe tôi đi dạy ba năm rồi mà tôi có 3 4
năm kinh nghiệm A cái chắc bạn 2 năm
kinh nghiệm đi làm thực tế là cũng được
chuyện thôi
đã
3 năm đi dạy ở trường người khác nghe
ngoài em ạ
à mà không chỉ những là bao Nam đấy số
giờ tôi đứng ở trên lớp rất là lớn luôn
số rồi phải đứng trên lớp và khẳng định
hơn 1.000 giờ rồi nhìn giống nhỉ nhỉ Còn
nói quá nhỉ có
một ngày có thể làm 8 tiếng thì à 125
ngày tuổi thì ít cho ít quá chậm anh
nhằm ngày có ít luôn
Ừ tôi làm ba năm nữa nhé
Ừ Ừ
cứ cho là chắc chắn là phải hơn 2.000
đến 3.000 giờ 4.000 nghe vậy thôi chứ
trọng nhưng mà tôi làm 35 ngày nào cũng
làm hơn có thể hơn 8 tiếng này ra tôi
khẳng định được số giờ tôi đứng trên lớp
mấy nghìn dầu rồi
cho nên là tôi nghĩ ở
có nơi hôm trước tôi chắc chưa quen về
không khỏi là còn ơi hôm trước vừa ngắn
hơn tôi rồi tôi sẽ tôi có thể về bên bên
đấy để làm trưởng phòng đào tạo ở bên
này cơ một cái nhớ đấy là không phải một
trung tâm mà một công ty muốn mở chương
trình dạy cũng lập trình như này dậy dậy
từ thiện nghĩa dạy miễn phí cho các bạn
nào có nhu cầu công ty ấy muốn tổ chức
cái chương trình đấy và nó rỡ lâu dài và
muốn cho tôi về làm trưởng trưởng đào
tạo luôn phụ trách đào tạo chương trình
đấy nhưng mà nó ở hơi xa một tí và bởi
vì làm như thế sẽ làm full Khanh đến tôi
không Tôi tôi không nhận bây giờ bảo là
tôi làm parttime hiệu luận buổi tối thì
chắc là tôi còn cân nhắc à
anh không bây giờ không còn khái niệm
phỏng vấn đâu Bây giờ tôi tôi bảo vệ
thời ra tôi đi làm được tôi được phỏng
vấn chỉ để người ta hỏi về lương là
người ta
hỏi lại thực sự là xem kể cái CV mình có
đúng thế đất không ấy chứ phỏng vấn tôi
toàn được chuyển hàng xác định tiến hành
lấy ví dụ bây giờ nếu mà có bên nào đã
bên đấy mời về tôi không cần phải nộp
đơn ứng tuyển đâu
khi người ta mười tôi về thì chắc không
cần phải phỏng vấn gì cả
anh nói bạn kia hình như nó đúng Hình
như ở Misa vậy
vì nó không không phải vì sao kể cả nơi
Gửi cho tôi không phải Misa
Ừ
nhưng mà ép shop mời tôi về để mà tôi
dậy mà
ở nhà mạng AT Shop thì còn lâu lắm tội
ép sốt làm fulltime thì chắc là tôi định
là phải à
áo kiểu hết đi làm đây nữa
ở công ty đấy á từ tra lại đi
à à
A gọi bạn kia em bây giờ cây xong hết fa
chân sau vậy
anh không bảo em chuyến sau song Thực ra
đã không có lên nhét cái phần FBI trên
sâu ở trong cái cái cái
danh sách our làm các bạn cứ học word
sâu mới bắt đầu sang bên cơ bản học web
Cô bạn ấy ra thấy hơi hơi say say Bởi vì
thực ra là ép em chuyện sau đấy à Chỉ
nên học sau cái đồ ăn một này này nó phù
hợp để các bạn là đỡ bị thoáng nhất đỡ
bị choáng Khi mà khi mà học nhá p xong
mà bê lại nhảy sang đồ án luôn các bạn
bị choáng hội đấy à trường tôi dạy thêm
espier lại dạy cho vui với que chuyên
sâu và gần như nó lý thuyết nhiều dậy
vui thôi để các bạn đã mê thêm esquare
thôi chứ nó cũng không áp dụng gì mấy
ờ ờ
chứ còn để mà Đấy và bia các bạn học
xong FA chân sau xong thì có bạn cũng
chả giúp gì thật mà
Ừ
mai mà mình đã truyền cảm hứng cho vài
bạn cảm thấy queo cuốn chứ thừa fr một
cái gì là khó mà nó không Các bạn thấy
cuốn khó mà thấy
nói chung là cái niềm vui của công nghệ
của lập trình viên đó là khi mình thấy
cái lừa khó mà mình làm được nó tình cảm
thấy sướng đó ông đã có tí gọi là biết
được cái ưu và nhược của cái ngành này
và ông có phải thích điều đấy thì ông
theo được này này còn ông thấy nó khó
quá mà bỏ thì ông khó mà theo này
Ừ
ông Tiêu đề kia đèn bắt muỗi hình rồng ở
đền đã sinh tại sao có nhắc lại về vụ
này
vẫn khẳng định với ông đi mua này mắt
mũi này xin lỗi anh bốn trăm hơn mình
chăm Tôi tắm ngày đêm không Đã ngày đêm
nó nổ đom đóm đốt liên tục nếu mà ông là
sợ giật mình mấy ông mình không nên mua
thôi đây này cũng thể thay đem ngủ tía
nó khá sáng và hơi sáng không nên nói
chói quá
thì ra màu xanh để không hợp lại đèn ngủ
nhưng mà đi kiểu ông Nửa đêm ông đi vệ
sinh gì không Không cần mở thêm đèn pin
à à
Ừ
nếu không thể em thắc mắc gì à Hôm nay
chắc là chị thế được không ai cảm thấy ạ
Như vậy Nhắn
bữa là có tiêu đề là bảo vệ Tôi sẽ để
tiêu đề tôi sẽ đổ đè buổi tâm sự
[âm nhạc]
tâm sự
Ừ ok
cho bộ Hôm nay có còn có gì bảo vệ đâu
ở công ty mới à đấy tôi xem ạ
Anh iec I
It is she
anh em cho mày ông xem luôn cái gì đi
cũng chẳng có gì giấu tao làm gì
Bộ trưởng phòng trưởng nhóm đào tạo công
nghệ Hồi trước Và tôi là trưởng bộ môn
lập trình mã nguồn mở tất cả bên pp nhé
trước bộ môn này cho iPad nhưng thực ra
dưới mình sẽ một hai người
này làm phun tham
trả lương này thì ta là 20 triệu tất cả
hơi thấp so với trứng cũ rồi tôi không
quan trọng lương mà
vợ chồng mẹ ra hấp dẫn mà không mô tả
phụ trách giáo án giáo trình cái thử cái
này tôi làm được từng làm rồi Tôi làm
bằng tiếng Anh là loi mà ông thích thì
sẽ tài liệu tôi tôi vẫn khẳng định tôi
làm tài liệu giữa là trường Chỉ bởi vì
tôi không sai lỗi chính tả này ở gõ tôi
sẽ không bờ để cái kiểu một cách thừa ra
như này này như thế Sao lại vân vân vân
đợt 2 bao giờ bảo vậy à
Ừ nếu không được Chị hỏi lại mấy câu cũ
tôi buồn lắm Thế cũng trả lời nữa Anh
xem lại video hôm nay nhá
anh em 52
ờ ờ
cho mọi người
anh
xin làm ai tầm
khi tôi chẳng hiểu mày nói gì cả à
cô dạy Toán á Tôi từng
mà tôi từng học giỏi toán sau đó năm cấp
2 và 5 cấp 3 tôi không không không hướng
đến hoàn toàn mấy nữa nên mấy ông không
bảo tôi dạy Toán được
à à
Ồ không Tôi cũng không chuyên gia Suite
để nó dậy mấy ông này mình cái đấy luôn
à Thử tài liệu thì ông ở xem thử tài
liệu chứ tài liệu Đoàn Hà thời hiệu đoán
hay thì nó sẽ là trang chủ của
lazada.com đấy
ở
level hiện tại của mình ở ở công ty nó
chỉ tỉnh nó cũng gần như là tsuneo thôi
Lương bây giờ đang ở 19 triệu sau hai
lần được tăng lương
Ừ
nó nó không hẳn là nhiều lắm chị lấy
nghìn đô mà nhớ mà thực tế là mình đi
sang công ty khác thì mình có thể lên
đến 2 năm hoặc hơn rồi có thể thế và
còn kinh nghiệm mình đi dạy mình khẳng
định là mình
biết cách dậy rồi mình khẳng định và
mình mình chỉ kém về khoảng là quản lý
nhân sự với mình thật là một con người
không không đồng cảm người khác lắm đấy
là mình khó mà nói được người ta mình
nét việc quản lý nên sữa phải khá là
ngạc con người có gì ở phức tạp khó hiểu
lắm Mình mình không nói được người khác
làm gì ở đâu nhưng mà để mà làm à Chỗ
dạng là để mà Soạn giáo trình là xô để
vạch ra lộ trình để mà dậy các thứ thứ
thì mình không làm rồi nên mình nghĩa là
mình vẫn có thể làm được mình cái á
Ừ nếu có được sự mày mình gặp được cái
nhóm nào mà nhóm đấy cũng có tâm huyết
mà ngồi làm đấy thì thì mình có thể kiểu
hướng được mình làm đít đâu Mình hướng
được người ta
Ừ để mai cậu lên mình khẳng định được
vào cái trình độ dậy của mình cũng cũng
ổn rồi họ từng trải à
em ngồi thấp hơn ở trường cũng nhiều chứ
thành ra là thành ra là
cha mẹ mình đừng cho rằng không thích
điều đấy à
Ừ mình không dậy cấu trúc dữ liệu và
giải thuật vì mình cũng không rõ cả để
làm cho da mình học cái môn đấy ba lần
rồi đấy mình cũng sẽ chạy qua các bạn để
các bạn
mình sẽ chạy qua các bạn về viết thiết
kế cơ sở dữ liệu một cách biết một cái
tương đối thôi chứ tôi không dạy các bạn
lại về toán để mà làm cấu trúc dữ liệu
giải thuật đâu bởi vì được là học cái
đấy xong với ông chỉ biết Cái đấy để
tham khảo thôi được sau mềm thiết kế
database nó vẫn dựa trên rất nhiều tình
huống nữa không có cái nào là quy chuẩn
tối ưu hoàn toàn cả à à
à à E52 xin làm thực tập nhưng mà chưa
học xong phim Quốc có được không ạ Thực
ra các bạn hỏi câu này khá nhiều rồi em
đi thực tập như bây giờ em bị thiếu cái
nước này thì có nên lấy không thì các
bạn thay vì kiểu như thế các bạn nên tự
bổ sung kiến thức này kiến thức lấy
trước đã trước khi đi tụ tập tránh việc
là đi lại đi rồi người ta hỏi và thuận
chứ người ta phải đào tạo các bạn về cái
đấy
thì tốn thời gian các bạn ra trừ khi các
bạn không tự học được các bạn mình nên
đến đấy và người ta thúc các bạn thôi
ừ ừ
ở
cùng lắm nhưng đã đổi về Ừ Nếu thực sự
bạn đấy mà kiểu gì đấy nhiều ông chị sẽ
là kẻ dạng là có thể mặt trời rồi Đi xin
thực tập ở khá nhiều nơi bị đuổi thì
càng có thêm kinh nghiệm Nếu mà tư duy
kiểu như thế cũng được Nhưng mà đừng có
kiểu đổi về xong bị nạn đấy Nó kiểu toàn
cái xong thất tình đàn đấy không dám tán
tiếp đi thì nó khi nó các bạn bỏ nghề
cũng nhanh lắm
ở trường cũ lúc mấy zậy à Trường Cũ lúc
mấy dậy ông cải lương của giảng viên ấy
chắc là cũng để lại lệch thuê nữa nó chỉ
32 là ba triệu rưỡi thôi Nó khá thật
nhưng mà lương một tiếng nó dậy hồi đấy
thôi mới dậy tôi lương được một tiếng là
100.000 giờ
ạ sau đó về sau tôi tăng lên giá một
trăm tám tăng cao nhất lên là tháng 8
giờ
Ừ mà mày không thấy tôi dậy bao nhiêu
giờ Một tuần rồi có dậy hơn à à Một
tháng nữa chúng mà
tôi dậy à mà thậm chí là tôi còn dạy lớp
buổi tối nữa bởi lớp buổi tối còn được
lên lạnh 200 một giờ nữa
nó buổi tối dậy 3 tiếng này
à à
hai ba tiếng một ngày dậy 11 tiếng không
mà cứ cho là
180 đúng không nhận với 8 này cộng với 3
tiếng cứ 600 đúng không ạ
mỹ nhân với 7
rồi cộng với 3 a nhân 17 nhân với không
nhân 16 sóng này trong một tuần sau đó
nhân 14 tuần đi rồi + buổi 3500i
anh lớn hết không Tôi không nhớ lớn như
thế này đó như sẽ sai đấy
Ừ đúng nhỉ
3000 lớn được như thế này đâu
Anh nhớ là lần cắn nhẹ hơn bạn 36 triệu
thôi I
em
nghe như sai sai nhỉ Tôi đang nghĩa của
gì đó Sai sai ở đây ạ
Ừ đúng nhỉ
Ừ ừ đúng rồi không có phải ngày nào tôi
cũng dậy Buổi tối sẽ đâu ạ
công
viên này đã 38 triệu rồi á nhiều ấy nhỉ
Tôi thấy xe sai bởi Hồi đấy thôi thế là
một phần là tôi không để ý tiền bạc Anh
ra là tiền về tài khoản tôi cũng kệ thôi
có gì kiểu thỉnh thoảng rút tiền ra để
đi mua gì đó
anh không để ý tiền bạc nó bảo rồi
Ừ thôi chỉ nhớ chắc chả ra Hồi đấy tôi
sẽ dư ra không có thể nghĩ tiền không có
con hơi đấy tôi thấy có con flagship
Xiaomi mới ra thông tôi chỉ cần chi đúng
nửa số lượng tôi mua được còn đầy thương
nhớ hết á đến bây giờ tôi vẫn đang dùng
nó này không phải Mỗi năm phải thay một
con mời đâu nhé Nó đang nói hồi đấy Tối
dư giả rồi Hình này dùm cái vỏ thu mua
luôn
Còn bây giờ thì kiểu kiểm tra trong còn
mang điểm A
vi phạm 96 học Bách Khoa cơ khí Rẽ sang
là mái đi ạ Ở
Ừ
thì ông à Cái văn mẫu
em biết appa Java thì xin lưu tập được
không nên nên làm đồng cái sản phẩm gì
đó đã chứ hỏi với một lý thuyết thì
không không nên đi thực tập được ờ
à à à à
các
video về gà tôi không xem mình video Tôi
mới xem được 23 video của biến F8 mỗi
tội không
tội không xem nhiều mới video làm đâu
nếu không gả tôi xem Thuận cả cũng xem
đâu Ờ ờ
họ Xem đôi khi tủi thân mèo bởi vì cảm
thấy người ta đang đứng ở cũng học hỏi
vài cái nhưng mà cũng tủi thân
anh lên mãng cầu thấy bể Biết đâu có cái
đoạn này mình dạy hay hơn người ta chẳng
hạn có lời dạy hay hơn nhưng mà người ta
lại được nhiều người biết đến hơn nhé
buồn
à à
315 15 lên một tháng được 15 470 đô
- 1 năm 1 tháng 8 triệu
39 chéo chín triệu chín triệu chưa Tại
sao ở trên theo nằm nghỉ à
ở mỗi đã Ánh trợ cấp 0,75 nghĩa là
750.000 không làm được 12 tháng mỗi
tháng 750 nghìn thôi nghỉ đi ông ơi
Ừ đúng rồi Mình thấy S8 thì dậy à khá
đầy đủ chi tiết
cho anh anh đấy không bỏ sót cái gì cả
Anh ấy dậy da diết mình đã bỏ qua khá
nhiều cái để mình muốn tối dàn đi để cho
bởi vì mình mình dậy trực tiếp rồi và
mình từng chạy thử nâng cao một tí cho
vài lớp khá nó rồi và có phải bạn kiểu
nhìn mặt Kiểu tao không muốn học nữa
thiệu thế thành ra tôi mấy cái kiểu giảm
đi khá nhiều cái
Ừ anh dậy hưởng theo kiểu dạng là bởi vì
nó một phần nào nó cũng là Online Đó
cũng là video
lưu lại nữa thành các bạn vẫn thể xem đi
xem lại để hiểu nhìn thế nào cả Oanh
hướng đến dậy à Cậu rất là kỹ rất là chi
tiết và rất là chuyên nghiệp Còn tôi
Hướng dậy là là đúng kẹo dạng như vậy
trên lớp nghĩa là ông học buổi nào ông
hiểu luôn buổi đấy hoặc là ông chỉ còn
xem lại một tí ông hiểu chúng mày dạng
như các anh Đấy anh Đấy ra kèo dậy riêng
cái số video thấy khác biệt ở rất nhiều
video và và kiểu nó chi tiết quá hay ra
là kiểu tôi nghĩa là nếu mà một người
mới vào Tôi từng nói vụ đấy rồi Nếu một
người mới vào khi mà nhìn thấy kiểu
hỗ trợ tầm 200 người video để ngồi học
người nguy cơ bản cho dù ở mỗi video thì
ra nó chuyển 5 phút thôi có
số lượng số thời lượng cái đồng gộp lại
khi không còn ít hơn so cái danh sách
web Tuấn một này của tôi nhưng mà nhìn
nói bị nạn đấy nếu hiểu à à à
ừ ừ
cho tôi biết là ông ông để sót cái video
Xem sinh viên đi thực tập rồi tôi biết
mà Nhưng tôi không xem đâu tôi tỉnh của
tôi nó hơi bị ngược do đó ông gạ tôi làm
cái gì đó thì đó không phải tôi làm thêm
này nó hơi bị à
bộ forlan 1 tháng 9 triệu Nếu là là nó
thế là trung bình mà thế là cơ bản thôi
không không Sắp cũng không cao
Cái đấy là một năm kinh nghiệm hoặc cảm
mới nhận vào thì thấy ổn tốn còn nếu
fulspec đương nhiên sẽ giúp E
Anh
bảo vệ đợt 2 thì chắc chắn là tôi sẽ mời
ép shop này mà tôi sẽ đăng lên đi cần có
thể mời vài nhân tố tuyển dụng về nữa
này và tôi sẽ mời cả đồng nghiệp tôi dậy
ở chiến trường trưởng cũ của tôi để mà
tham dự để màn hình đá Mấy ông đấy
đấy ít nhất là như thế trước mà tôi đang
nghĩa như thế có thể Cả anh Mạnh Tuấn
nữa sản có gì mấy anh ở trong nhà trong
như tiên
tham dự nữa không Chẳng lẽ cứ đùa bán
một này tôi định Mờ rồi nhưng mà tất cả
là
mấy ông vẫn chỉ đang hơi bị à Vẫn chưa
chưa nghiệp lắm vẫn còn đang run rồi sẽ
Thôi tất cả là
ý chính vì không chuyên nghiệp với kiểu
ví dụ để mình hôm nay chẳng có nhóm nào
b hôm nay mời một người nào đó về thôi
thấy chả nhóm bảo vệ thì tôi biết nói gì
với họ chẳng biết nói gì với họ thôi Tôi
buồn lắm
ừ ừ
Ừ đúng rồi Mỗi người một cách dạy không
so sánh với cả chỉ người ta hướng đến
cái gì Mục tiêu người ta hướng đến là gì
tiêu Mình hướng đến nó khác nhau thì
không thể so sánh được không ạ ạ
à à
em làm phần mềm có nên học cao học không
không tối nói về bằng cấp nếu có không
bảo qua bằng cấp thị thực Mấy ông không
cần phải học lý thuyết nhiều quá học lý
thuyết nhiều quá mấy ông
Ừ nếu học sư chết mạng này
Ừ chứ đừng có học ở chiến trường mấy
thầy cô lấy cũng chỉ biết lý thuyết đôi
khi ở bên người thuyết suông ấy không ăn
rộn thực tế được đâu
Ừ ok Nói chung ở bây giờ có vẻ mà
cũng khá dài rồi hôm nay cũng chẳng bảo
vệ gì cả buổi hôm nay tặng kết thúc thôi
nhỉ Thế ông còn thắc mắc gì không Không
bữa mày chắc là tạm kết thúc
cơ hội cho mình sẽ tính sao
ở buổi buổi sao à
ở buổi sao cha tôi ngại quá dại bên A pp
nâng cao
Chào mấy ông nhé
ừ ừ